what are we trying to fix the economy is
on fire
leave it alone people living in cities
like new york in los angeles to san
francisco if biden's plan
went through they would be the highest
taxed individuals
on earth is that american nah i don't
think so
[Music]
if you're going to tax corporations and
i
i would argue i don't know i'm not i
think you ought to tax individuals and
you know corporations you want them to
do as well as they possibly can
in your country to provide jobs and
generate taxes and every
that that people pay and everything else
so but let's say you'd assume you are
going to tax corporations
what's wrong with this what's wrong with
doing it this way
well first of all let me be the skeptic
for a moment
and say that looking back historically
g20 and g7 meetings
they're essentially cocktail parties
nothing wrong with that a chance for the
leaders to get together
it's hold hands kumbaya and let's tax
everybody 15
the chance that this happens i would
argue practically
zero here's why about two-thirds or at
least
at least half of these various
constituents who go to these meetings
are facing re-election very shortly
number two is just because they
say they want to do it at a cocktail
party they have to go back to their
geographies and pass it in their
own governments and that in itself is
going to be a huge challenge
just take ireland for example i happen
to be an irish citizen
i'm pretty familiar with dublin and
malahi the suburbs around there
go in and have a pint of guinness with
any irish citizen
about the idea that janet yellen or the
us or the europeans or the british
can tell them what to do i'd love to
repeat what they say joe but i
unfortunately can't i'll tell you the
chance that happens in ireland
zero and the irish understand the
potential of nation building
and corporate taxation is part of the
weaponry the competitiveness of it
that's how you're competitive you can do
other things to raise taxes in all
countries including the u.s
which does not want to put a vat tax in
place but all of the rest of these
european countries are trying to go
after big tech this way
because they have no tech sector they
regulated out of existence a long time
ago
the only way they can get any tax
revenue is to litigate sue
and join on and efforts like these which
makes no sense
this is going nowhere and that is why
the market doesn't care
and competitiveness of of nations will
remain
and those that provide a better
environment for corporations will get
the jobs
like ireland like hungary and like
others who are saying
we don't care what you think let's
compete
john do you think it's a good idea to
both of these things to have this global
minimum and to raise taxes in this
country back to 28 percent on
corporations
let's deal with the 15 which is the
agreement globally
uh and by the way that we're down from
40 is a 40
drop in taxes from 2017 and corporate
taxes have been basically dropping
for the last uh 70 years as well as well
as individual tax rates but let me say
this i think this is i think this this
global plan
by president biden is brilliant and
secretary yellen is brilliant
uh no more high in the ball no more
ducking uh when i go
to to orlando florida i pay taxes when i
go there on whatever i buy
when i go to this morning to utah i'm
paying taxes when i go there
i i you know i'm happy to support where
i'm at and by the way my friend
kevin is must be the most optimistic
pessimist i
i know or the pessimistic optimists that
i know i mean he's sitting with this
green background
but you can't pay for that green
background environmental sustainability
unless somebody actually invests in r d
wherever he happens to be sitting at you
every company
who the brain every growth company
invest in their product
and their home court even the business
roundtable joe
uh said that we need to put the
stakeholder
above the mere shareholder those two
things are connected
the business roundtable is agreeing in
their principles with what president
biden is doing
uh i had dinner with the deaf secretary
of treasury last week i thought
this is a genius and it shows american
leadership again by the way
america has not been respected like this
on the global stage for a long time
only america could do this only america
would do this
uh it is good for everybody the more
hiding the ball it provides reinvestment
and it will happen kevin
it will happen uh uh i don't want to say
like what i know
but i have very good reason to believe
this will happen
on merit um and i don't think people are
talking what what people are against
this
is the president clinton great quote
it's hard to get somebody to agree to
the truth
when the lie is paying their paycheck
okay so
if you are a place that's hiding the
ball you're not for this
but i love this because this this says
the stop the games is knock it off
and reinvest in your home court a
reasonable by the way a reasonable tax
rate
uh i don't want to remind everybody the
tax rate was close to 100 on the
individual my dad
back after world war ii with a
republican president
so we we are we are whining about very
very
nice spilled milk here this is good for
all right you must have a lot to
say now kevin after that well frankly
um let's talk about tax rates in the u.s
because my good friend john just brought
that up
a reasonable tax rate right now the u.s
sits exactly in the middle of the g20 in
corporate taxation
if biden proposals were put in place it
would go from the middle of the pack
to the very highest tax jurisdiction of
the g20
now i don't see how that's good for
business i don't think that's the list
you want to be on the top of
and frankly people living in cities like
new york
where you are joe and boston and
california and los angeles and san
francisco if biden's plan went through
they would be the highest taxed
individuals on earth
is that american nah i don't think so so
i don't think this is going to happen
because we know the reversions would
start immediately where would they go
to hungary and to ireland all these
companies would follow the path of least
resistance
for their shareholders just like they
did a couple of decades ago
when we were over taxing them let's not
make the same mistake
again what are we trying to fix the
economy is on
fire leave it alone don't touch it let
it recover on its own
it doesn't need any more government and
it certainly at this point
does not need more taxes let's wait
i want to congratulate the biden
administration by the way on the great
job they did on
vaccination rollout and also if they get
through this skinny infrastructure deal
those are good for the country
but this idea to build your mandate
around taxing everybody in the world and
making your own country
the tops tax jurisdiction on earth is a
bad
idea not good for america not good for
jobs
and by the way i can't hire anybody
right now because i'm competing for with
the government
till the end september it's extremely
frustrating
people that i'm paying are also getting
paid by the government
we got to stop doing this to ourselves
this is absolutely crazy
yeah uh john final thoughts and and you
know that 90 percent rate you're talking
about out there
no one paid that you know that there
were so many ducks in any deductions
rich people were paying less than they
pay now back then now
what is a fair rate for people john is
50 okay or you want to go above that if
you work
through june uh well into july
uh to pay off what you owe the
government
isn't that enough or there should still
be more
well i don't want us to be a nordic
country where the rate's about 50
percent that's not where we should be
there's a lot of room with all due
respect joe's you just said you're just
contradicting yourself there are
write-offs and
all carve outs look i'm highly
compensated and i i
have very interesting ways legal ways to
to uh minimize my tax burden while by
paying what i do what i deserve
let me go back though to the substance
of this kevin just said something is
ridiculous right
we're 13 13 in the world in
infrastructure we're the number one
economy in the world as he just said but
we're 13 on infrastructure so there are
times where you have to invest more
by the way i do agree with kevin there
are cities like new york that probably
are over taxed in the state
but but as a but on a national level we
we we are the special forces team here
and we are the roads are falling apart
apart my my wheels are falling apart
coming apart in potholes in my city we
have got to
uh ride this economy on a road that can
actually hold it and i don't mean just
physical roads i mean people roads
infrastructure human capital you've got
to reinvest in your product you want to
be netflix in this example
not blockbuster which been out of
business because it'd be focused on the
short term
versus the long term if you like that
video wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe